TOBY SMITH: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to Taming Your
Cloud Applications
with Intelligent Monitoring.
We're glad you
could make it today.
My name's Toby.
I'm an engineering
lead here at Google.
I work on cloud logging,
monitoring, and alerting
DAN BELCHER: Hello, everyone.
I'm Dan Belcher.
I'm a product manager
on the same team.
I'm what they call a
noogler because I started
at the company just
last month, when
a company that I had
co-founded, called
Stackdriver became
part of Google.
TOBY SMITH: Super happy
to have you here, Dan.
DAN BELCHER: Thanks, Toby.
TOBY SMITH: All right.
So if you've ever developed
any sort of application
and you've had any
user base whatsoever,
there's probably a time
when you've had this moment.
That awful sort of,
oh crap, feeling
that accompanies
that recognition
that your users figured
out an awful problem
with your application.
And you had no idea
it was going on.
You're not alone.
Pretty much everyone
who develops anything
has been in this boat
at one point or another.
But sure it sure
doesn't make it any fun.
When it happens, you're kind
of pulling your hair out.
And as you can tell, I must have
been in these situations a lot.
Because you already
have a full-time job,
you're just trying to
develop the world's greatest
application.
And now suddenly you
have two or three jobs.
You're still trying to
develop the world's greatest
application.
But now you're trying
to fix that critical bug
that your users were so
helpful in helping you find.
Thank you, users.
And if it's just you and another
person, like maybe me and Dan,
well you might be on the
hook for sending email
and apologies,
writing blog posts,
maybe even calling up customers
and saying, hey, we're on it.
We have this.
We're going to fix it for you.
You totally don't
need to go look
at the world's second
greatest application.
Why does this happen?
It doesn't need to,
especially in the cloud.
We have all sorts of information
about how applications behave
that can help save you
from this sort of thing.
That sounds nice, but
it's not always that easy.
So first of all, just
a quick show of hands.
How many of you here
are completely new
to cloud development,
have never done it before?
All right.
There's only a handful of you.
That's fantastic.
And we welcome you to
the cloud sometime soon.
But if you are coming from
a more traditional sort
of application
development environment,
you might be used to a world
where you write your code.
You test the hell
out of it because you
want to make sure
you're giving the best
product to the customer
that you possibly can.
But at some point,
you just kind of
have to throw it over the wall.
You have to package it
up and ship it out there.
Someone buys it.
They install it on
a computer that you
have absolutely no
visibility into.
When that happens,
you're just left
wondering how your application's
behaving in the wild.
And if that's the environment
that you're used to,
you might not have
any expectation
that there is more
to be learned,
that there is logging and
monitoring information
about your live
running applications
that you could have.
So I guess the
rest of you are all
die hard cloud developers who
have been around the block
for a few years.
You folks might have
a different sort
of perspective on what's
available out there.
There's a lot of
really great vendors
doing fantastic
things in the logging,
monitoring, and alerting spaces.
But you have to go
out and find them.
You have to do some research.
You have to understand
what's available.
You have to pick and
choose from this a la carte
sort of offering,
instead of just
being able to rely
on your platform
to provide a single pane of
glass to the core functionality
that your application needs.
Wouldn't it be nice
if something just
gave you that out of the box?
We agree.
We think that it should
be easier than this.
And so that's why we're
so excited to be talking
to you about Google
Cloud Monitoring today.
With Google Cloud
Monitoring you don't even
need to know it exists.
If you're just getting
started and you're
coming from a more
traditional background,
you might not even think,
oh, I need to set up logging.
Oh, I need to set up
monitoring because I'm
going to care about it later.
We do that for you.
So when you do care about
it, the data's there for you.
But we're also able
to grow with you.
If you're more
sophisticated and you've
been looking at other
vendors, and maybe you're
even using some
of them today, we
can give you some of
the core functionality
that you need without ever
leaving the Google Cloud
Platform sandbox.
You get all the information
about how your application
is behaving in one place.
That's why I'm super
excited that Dan's
up here on stage with me.
He and his team with
Stackdriver developed
a world class cloud
monitoring application.
And now they're bringing
their real world experience,
their domain expertise, and
most of all a fantastic product
to Google Cloud Monitoring.
They really form
the pillar of what
we're going to be
talking about today.
And with Stackdriver and
with Google Cloud Platform
you can go from knowing
absolutely nothing
about logging and
monitoring to setting up
sophisticated dashboards
and alerts in no time.
Dan's going to talk
a little bit more
about the types of
data we get together
and give to you to help you
understand your applications.
DAN BELCHER: Thank you, Toby.
so this is all about visibility.
And so what we set out to
do is give you visibility
into your entire application
stack running on the platform.
And just a quick overview,
in terms of how it works.
So we think of the application
stack in three layers.
The first layer of the
application stack at the base
is the cloud platform itself.
If you're using App Engine, if
you're using Compute Engine,
Cloud SQL, Cloud
Pub, and so forth.
And so that's the bottom
layer in the stack.
On top of that you
have the systems layer.
Right.
So these are
typically VMs running
in Google Compute,
where historically it's
been difficult to get really
good information in terms
of the performance
of VMs themselves.
And whether it's
Windows or Linux,
we support a variety
of operating system.
And we have an agent that we
use to integrate with the VMs.
And then on top of that you
have your application stack.
For the many of you who
have been developing
in the cloud for
some time, you're
probably using one or
more of these components,
whether it's Redis or Nginx
or Apache or Cassandra
or Elasticsearch, and so forth.
And we use the agent
framework to integrate
with those services natively.
So we are able to monitor
those services as well.
And when we think
about giving you
visibility, what that
really comes down to
is log data, metric
data, and metadata.
So we're capturing all
this data from all three
layers of the application.
We're storing it in
massively scalable databases.
And then we're making
it useful for you.
And so that starts
with visualization.
We'll talk a lot about really
rich charting and dashboard
capabilities here.
But beyond visualization, if
you're looking at a chart,
usually you're trying
to analyze the data.
And so what we've
done is built tools
into the platform to analyze
the data on your behalf.
So that's the analysis
capabilities in the product.
And then finally,
it doesn't really
help anybody if the
platform discovers an issue
and you don't know about it.
And so there's a really
flexible notification framework
to let you know
when issues occur,
whether you're at lunch
with your teammates
or, unfortunately, asleep
at 3 o'clock in the morning.
So that's how the
system works as a whole.
We think a lot about the
one or two developers
working from a home office or
a garage and the experience
for them getting started.
And so to illustrate that,
we'll talk a little bit
about the Walkshare application.
So this is an
example application
that you might build some day.
If you didn't catch
the I/O keynote,
the Walkshare application
is a simple app
they basically tracks your
walk around San Francisco,
for example, and
makes it easy for you
to share that with friends.
The Walkshare application
has three App Engine modules,
and it uses a number
of Google services.
And what we'll focus on here
is the front end interface that
connects to a Leaderboard
module on App Engine,
and then that module itself
connecting to a set of Redis
nodes, a cluster of Redis
nodes on Google Compute Engine.
And so we'll use
this as an example
of how you can get going with
cloud logging and monitoring.
So in terms of this
App Engine module,
the Leaderboard
Module, the first thing
that you might want
to ask yourself is,
is it up and running
and available to users?
And we'll show you how you can
configure endpoint or uptime
checks to notify you when
it goes down completely
or when it's
inaccessible to users.
Then we'll talk about default
dashboard, so dashboards
and charts that give you
insight into the performance
of that module.
We'll talk about how you can use
log data to get to root cause
and also how you can create
very, very simple alerting
policies to notify you when
issues occur in the future.
OK.
So we'll start with
getting started
monitoring that module
that's running on App Engine.
The first thing that
we'll want to do
is configure an endpoint
check so that we
know if the Leaderboard is
no longer available at all.
And so Toby's going to go
to services and endpoints.
And he'll configure
a check to basically
connect to a specific
host name every minute
to poll it every minute.
And what this is basically
doing is instructing
our infrastructure of probes
deployed around the world
to connect to that
host every minute
and confirm availability.
So we'll specify a
protocol and a path
and say that we want it
to happen every minute.
And Toby will test the
endpoint to be sure
that we're connecting.
TOBY SMITH: Huzzah!
DAN BELCHER: So we had
a successful connection
in the test.
And we would save this.
And now it's up and running.
That will just keep running.
And you can see that we
have an existing endpoint
check in place.
And for each of
our five regions,
we are actually
healthy right now.
So this means that we've
gotten a 200 response
from each of the regions.
And we're good to go
from that perspective.
So we're up and running.
Next, we'd want to see if
there are any performance
issues related to the
App Engine module.
So we'll go to our
App Engine dashboard.
And this gives us an overview
of the performance for this App
Engine project.
And so on the left, you'll
see that the format here
is of kind of an
operational dashboard.
So we have key configuration
information on the left
and then key metrics
on the right.
And if we scroll down,
looking at the metrics,
we can see latency, network
I/O, response codes,
response styles.
And actually, Toby,
response codes,
it looks like we have
something interesting here.
TOBY SMITH: Hold the phone, Dan.
DAN BELCHER: Yeah.
So we have what looks like
a spike in 500 errors that
happened at some point
over the last hour.
So first I might want to
zoom into that time period.
So we can just click and
zoom right in the chart.
And that'll zoom
all of our charts
into that time period
for the module.
And so we can see if there
are any correlating issues.
It looks like there was a
slight increase in latency,
a little bit more
network load, and again
this spike in 500 errors.
So what we don't
know now is which
module is emitting the errors.
So we'll click on
the modules tab,
and we'll see the same
metrics broken out by modules.
So we can scroll down
to the 500 errors
and then highlight over the
ones where we see the spike
and discover that
this is our Redis.
Module.
That's the Leaderboard module.
DAN BELCHER (WHISPERING):
It's always Redis.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN BELCHER: It's
not always Redis.
So this is the
Leaderboard module.
It looks like there's
an issue here.
And now we want to try
to get to root cause.
Right.
Why are we seeing this
increase in errors?
And one great way to do that
is to take a look at the logs.
So we'll go back to
our developers console.
We'll click on logs.
And then you'll see that
we bring all the log
data from our App Engine
projects into a single place.
And we can filter the module
to only that Redis module.
And sure enough, we see that
the errors are abundant.
And Toby, what do
we see if we look
at the details on this one?
TOBY SMITH: That we're sad.
DAN BELCHER: That we're sad.
TOBY SMITH: Well, it looks
like an invalid password, Dan.
DAN BELCHER: All right.
Well, the good news
is we found the issue.
And also it's a
pretty quick fix.
What this means is
probably the Redis module
is having trouble connecting
to the Redis cluster.
We're using the
wrong password there.
So maybe one of the teammates
here in the audience
could fix it.
But maybe, Toby,
why don't we turn
on live streaming for
the logs to confirm
that it's still
happening right now?
And indeed, it looks like it is.
All right.
So that's how you can use
the logs from App Engine
to get to root
cause on an issue.
Now finally, the good news
is that we found the issue.
We happened to be looking
at a dashboard at the time.
I don't know who here likes
to spend all day staring
at dashboards, besides Toby
and I. So what you'd want to do
is configure an alerting
policy so that you're
notified if the issue
occurs in the future.
So we'll go, and we'll
create a learning policy.
And we'll specify that
we'd like to be alerted
when 500 errors increase
for that specific module.
So we'll select the module.
And then on the
next screen, we'll
say that we want it
to alert on 500 errors
when they go above
say 10 per second
for more than five minutes.
And one good thing
that we do here
is give you a
preview of the metric
or a historical
overview of the metric
and how frequently
it would have fired
if you set it at that level.
OK.
So I've saved that condition.
And now I can configure
a notification.
So this is to say
whether you want
it to email you or send
an SMS, and so forth.
And so here we'll say
we'll generate an email.
And because maybe we're just
getting started, and it's Toby
and I in our garage, we'll
send an email to both of us
when we see these 500s.
OK.
So that's how you can create
a simple alerting policy that
notifies you when there's
an issue in App Engine.
OK.
So we've demonstrated how you
can configure an endpoint check
that will notify you if there's
an issue if it goes down,
if the front end goes down.
We've demonstrated
how you can get access
to rich metrics for App Engine.
That'd be a very
similar experience
if you were looking at the other
Google Cloud Platform services.
And then how you can
dig into the log data
to get to root
cause, and finally,
how you can now configure
alerts to notify you
when issues occur.
OK.
So that's getting started.
Now, if we were very fortunate
and our project worked out,
things would get
serious after a while,
as we have more customers
and a more complex system,
and a larger team.
TOBY SMITH: We're totally
getting serious, Dan.
So right.
When you're first
getting started,
you just want things
to get out of your way.
As you're starting
to get serious,
you want more sophistication
from your monitoring
and logging platform.
And we're here to
help you with that.
But what do we mean when
we say we transition
from getting started
to getting serious?
I mean, we have a
couple cute slides.
But what are we
really talking about?
So when you're getting
started, typically you
develop on machines.
You might only have
three or four of them
in your whole fleet.
You probably care
very deeply about each
and every one of them.
They're all special flowers, and
they probably all have names.
You probably have one that's
running your front end.
running your back end.
There's probably a couple that
are running your data store
or something like that.
When one of those goes down,
it means something catastrophic
for your application.
As you start getting serious,
that becomes less true.
You start thinking less
about individual machines
and more about clusters.
You start understanding
a little bit less
about the entirety
of your architecture.
And you start to
understand, well
I basically know how this
thing works over here,
but there's other
folks who are working
on that who know a lot
more about it than I do.
When something's broken
when you're getting started,
again, you just have these
three or four machines.
It's a big deal.
If that front end goes down,
your entire site is gone.
If the back end goes down, all
of your fantastic data is gone,
and you can't show anything
interesting to users.
When you're getting serious,
well you think about things
because, for the most part,
when things get large enough,
something's always broken.
So really the question
you want to answer is,
is it something I care about?
So if you have those
same three or four
machines that you used
to use for everything
when you were
getting started, you
might have re-purposed them
into a Redis cluster a long time
ago.
And now, if all four of those go
down, you just might not care.
That's something you
get to on Monday morning
while you're having your coffee.
But on the other hand, if
you're experiencing 500 errors
that you're throwing
to your users,
you always care about those.
That is something
that you want to have
to wake up in the
middle of the night for.
So you need to understand
what the difference
between these different
types of failures
is when you're getting serious.
When you're getting started,
the development team's just you.
Like I said, you have
everything in your head.
You know the entire system.
This is your baby.
As you start
getting serious, you
might have a team of
10, 20, 30, 40 people.
Your grasp on the particulars
of what's going on
is starting to
slip a little bit.
You still talk a good
game in meetings,
but really you don't
know exactly what's
going on all the time.
So Dan's going to
talk now about what
it means when you
start getting serious
and how we can help you still
understand your application.
DAN BELCHER: Thanks, Toby.
And so the Walkshare
application is actually
an app that's on the
verge of a serious app.
Right.
Because with this
red Redis cluster,
things start to look more
like a distributed system,
and so some of these patterns
that Toby talked about
are going to emerge.
Right.
With a cluster, we'll talk
about how you can get visibility
into that cluster
that's running on GCE
and get the right
metrics out of it.
We'll talk about how now
that you have a distributed
system that's
fairly complex, you
may want to create a
view that's all your own,
and how you can take
information from different parts
of the platform and
create custom dashboards.
We'll talk about how you
can get log data, access
to log data for VMs that are
running on Google Compute
Engine.
And then finally, how you
can create alerting policies
that are cluster aware.
Right.
This is a really important part
of managing distributed systems
in the cloud.
And so we'll show
you how things look
when your kind of
getting serious.
In this case, we'll
start with the home
page for Cloud Monitoring.
One thing you'll
see on the left here
is that we've identified
a couple groups of nodes.
Right.
The first is this Redis cluster
that we were talking about.
And so we've
discovered these groups
by analyzing some
metadata around the VMs.
In this case, we saw that
there was a pattern where
you had a lot of machines that
the name started with Redis.
All right.
And you can define
your own groups.
The great thing here is
that they're filters.
They're dynamic.
So if I add a new
Redis node, the machine
will automatically be
added into the group.
And you can do this.
You can define groups based on
accounts or regions or tags.
There are lots of different
ways that you can do this.
OK.
So this notion of a
group is really important
as you scale up.
And now we'll want
to get visibility
into that group of Redis nodes.
And so we'll go, and
we'll take a look
at our dashboard
for the Redis nodes.
Here you see the same
operational dashboard,
where on the left we have the
configuration of the service,
and on the right we
have key metrics.
Now, out of the box with no
configuration, what you'll have
is visibility into
CPU, as well as
network and storage
I/O for the VMs.
But if you deploy
the agent, you'll
have access to much more
detailed system level metrics.
So this would include
CPU Steal, memory,
how full each of the
disks attached to the VM
are, and then also information
on specific processes running
on the machine.
OK.
So this is the
visibility that you
get into kind of the
core system stats.
But also with a simple
configuration file
you can tell the
agent to monitor
Redis on those machines.
And once you put that
file on the machines,
then the agent will
know to pull Redis stats
and send them to our service.
And then you're done.
What will happen is the
Redis statistics will show up
on the dashboard automatically.
We'll know that
they're Redis machines.
You don't have to do any other
configuration to get visibility
into the Redis status.
In here, you see, we'll have
Redis connections and memory
and expired keys, and so forth.
And these metrics are
also now available
throughout the system.
OK.
Now, if we saw an issue as we
had with the App Engine module,
we could dive in and
take a look at the logs.
But before we do that,
let's take a quick look
at how we would create a
custom dashboard that gives us
visibility into different
parts of our app.
So first, you see we have
our custom dashboard.
I've added a couple charts to
this dashboard as defaults.
The first, on the left you see
an overview of production CPU
across a larger cluster.
All right.
Now, if you've managed
large environments
you know they can be a little
bit difficult sometimes
when you have too
much data on a chart.
Anyone have that experience?
Yeah, yeah.
I guess a bunch of you.
One great thing here is
we can go to full screen
mode for that chart
to get a broader view.
And then it looks like there's
some interesting activity here.
So what I'll do is we'll
go into x-ray mode.
All right.
And x-ray mode is a
way, especially when
you have a lot of time
series on a chart, a way that
makes it easier for you see
for you to see the trends.
So you can see here we
have a set of machines,
it looks like in the cluster,
that are hovering around
40% CPU utilization.
We also have this
band of machines
that are hovering
right around 60.
And then there's some
noise right up at the top.
So what I'd like to do is sort
by volatility in the legend
to see what the most
volatile machines are.
And in fact, it
looks like there's
one machine that's
alerting API that's
much more volatile
than the others.
So this might be a
case where we want to--
Often we want to terminate
the node and start a new one,
but in this case, we may
want to dive into the logs
to see what's going
on with that node.
OK.
So again, we can go back
to our cloud console
and access the logs.
And now for the first
time, we have rich access
to the logs for the
machines running on GCE.
And the great thing
here is you don't
have to SSH into the machines
to get access to the data.
All of the log data
from all of the machines
come into one place.
All right.
And it's easily sortable and
filterable, and so forth.
OK.
So this is how you would
go into the log data
for machines that
live on GCE to help
diagnose issues in this cluster.
OK.
And then finally,
in this case, we
can also look at the
live updating logs.
Finally and probably most
importantly, alerting.
Right.
So this is a cluster.
It's dynamic.
We're adding, removing,
and recycling machines
all the time.
And so what I want to do
is create alerting policies
at the cluster level.
All right.
And because we have this group
capability we can do that.
So we'll specify
here that we want
to create a policy to tell
us if more than a third
of the machines in the cluster
are, let's say, over-utilized.
So CPU is over 50%.
OK?
So this will only trigger
if more than a third
of the machines in the cluster
are over 50% CPU utilization.
And this doesn't matter if
you add 10 more machines
to the cluster.
It will automatically
incorporate those
into the algorithm.
Here again, we see a preview.
We can now add a
second condition.
So because I'm thinking
about the cluster,
I might want to think about the
health of the cluster overall.
So I'll aggregate the metrics.
I could do, say, the average
CPU across all the nodes
in the cluster.
And so we'll select our metric.
We'll specify the Redis cluster.
We'll choose CPU.
And then we'll
say, if the average
is over 40% percent
across the cluster.
Maybe this is a case
where it's telling us
we need some more capacity.
And we could have
just as easily done it
based on the standard deviation
of the 95th percentile
or fifth percentile
or otherwise.
Now also, given that
we have two conditions,
we didn't just create
two alerting policies.
We created two conditions
for the same policy.
And that's important
because we may not
want the alert to fire
unless both of the conditions
are true.
So you can imagine that you have
a metric for your App Engine
module connecting to Redis.
And you might want to look
at two different metrics
as conditions and then
only fire the alert
if both of the
conditions are true.
Here we have a larger team.
As Toby showed, we're
a successful crew.
We have 40 engineers.
And maybe this is a
serious enough issue
that I want to email everyone.
And so right in the
notification framework
you can say that you'd like
everyone to be notified.
But as Toby said, not
everyone knows exactly what's
going on in every
component of the system.
So we can also add read me
information to the policy,
so to say, if this
occurs, maybe you
want to try these three steps.
All right.
So that's how you can
create an alerting policy
in a more sophisticated
environment.
And you'll see
that there are lots
of options in terms of making
it really effective to alert
at the cluster level right
in the distributed systems
environment.
OK.
So this is how the
monitoring systems
can scale when you get
to a larger environment.
Finally, what Toby will talk
about is some of the lessons
that we've learned.
One of them is take advantage
of some of the integrations
that are built
into the platform.
So as you get
larger, it might be
fine to get an email alert when
things happen getting started.
But as you get
larger, you may have
a team that hangs
out in chat rooms
because you're spread
around the country.
And so you may want that to
trigger into a chat room,
in this case Campfire or
HipChat or whatever you use.
You may also have an operations
team and on-call rotations.
So if you use PagerDuty,
there's native integration
with PagerDuty so that we can
escalate issues directly there.
TOBY SMITH: All right.
Thank you, Dan.
As Dan said, we
know we've given you
kind of a whirlwind
tour of Google Cloud
Monitoring at this point.
And we really don't
expect you to remember
everything that we showed or all
the fiddly little menus that we
went through.
But if you remember
nothing else,
just take away a few things, and
when you do start using this,
you can be successful with it
and really make the most of it.
First of all, we talked
a bit about groups.
But groups become vital
as your team grows.
When you're just
getting started,
you might not care all
that much about groups.
But once you start getting
even 10, 15 machines,
this starts to
become invaluable.
You don't need to keep track of
which individual machines are
associated with
Redis, which ones
are associated with Cassandra.
As these things
grow and contract,
your alerting roles and
your monitoring dashboards
grow and contract too take
advantage of these things.
Plus it's just a
great way to navigate
the complexity of a
sophisticated system.
Second, go nuts.
Be your own person.
We provide a lot
of personalization
with the dashboards.
We have reasonable
suggestions for things
like App Engine and Compute
Engine, Cassandra and Redis.
But that's just
our guess for what
these dashboards
should look like.
If you disagree, go change it.
Add the metrics that you want.
Add the screens that you want.
You can bring in any
information, any data.
You can have any number
of these graphs on screen.
You can even do things like
drag them around and change
this color scheme if you want.
This is your system.
Make it your own.
And finally, we've talked
a lot about alerting.
But we really can't
emphasize enough both
how powerful and potentially
useless and dangerous
alerting can be if you
don't use it right.
So be thoughtful when
you're setting up
your alerting conditions.
Understand the questions that
you actually want to answer,
and go from there.
If you're alerting on, say, one
Cassandra latency problem that
lasts one minute, and
you're waking someone up
at 3:00 in the morning, your
team is not going to be happy.
By the time they wake
up, the problem's
probably resolved itself.
Even if it hasn't, the
rest of the cluster's
probably behaving normally.
Dan showed a few examples of
the sophisticated sort of rules
that you can apply to do
the things that you actually
want to accomplish
with your system.
So think about those.
Set the alerts up
so that they're
meaningful for your team,
and revisit them occasionally
as well.
The things that are
useful now might not
be the same things
that are useful
three months from now when
you've again doubled in size.
And that's it.
Thanks so much for coming
and listening to us
talk about Google
Cloud Monitoring.
We're super excited about it.
And we hope you are too.
DAN BELCHER: And we're really
excited that you decided
to spend an hour on your
Thursday afternoon with us.
We're also excited because today
we started the Trusted Tester
Program for Google
Cloud Monitoring.
And that means that if you're
a current Google Cloud Platform
customer, if you log into
your developer console,
you'll see a new link on the
left for dashboards and alerts.
If you click on that link,
you can request access
to the Trusted Tester Program.
Oh, yeah.
We can show you exactly
how that happens.
So you'll see
dashboards and alerts.
TOBY SMITH: Ba bum.
DAN BELCHER: If you
click there, you'll
see a button to request access.
Unfortunately, we can't grant
everyone access right away.
But certainly, we'll do
it as quickly as we can.
And then secondly, if you're
not a current cloud platform
customer, it's also good day.
And that's because you
can claim a $500 credit
to get started on the platform.
And at this point, thank
you very much, everyone.
We'd welcome any questions
or feedback that you have.
We'll just ask you to use the
mics here in the center aisle.
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions?
TOBY SMITH: Sure.
DAN BELCHER: Right
here in the front.
AUDIENCE: Hi, guys.
Thanks.
Great talk.
I was very impressed by
the metrics and alerting
that was demonstrated.
And I'm wondering
if there's a way
to alert on a single metric
that is comparing itself
to a different time.
DAN BELCHER: Oh.
Not yet.
Not today.
This is a request that
we've gotten in the past.
Great, great feedback,
something that we'll
take into consideration.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'd like to ask if it's
possible to create a custom
metrics and custom notification.
DAN BELCHER: So custom
metrics are not yet available.
They are something that
we hear loud and clear are
very important.
In fact, it's been our
number one request so far.
Custom notifications, what
you do have the ability to do
is configure a webhook as
a notification endpoint.
And so then you can just
specify the path of the webhook,
and we'll send the data there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAN BELCHER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Very impressing
tool I have to say.
DAN BELCHER: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: As an
experienced user on GCE,
my question is referring to
the extending of the agent.
That's what the custom metrics
I guess you're referring to.
Right?
At the moment, it's
impossible to extend the agent
from my own application?
DAN BELCHER: Today,
it is not supported
to add new plug-ins or
metrics to the agent.
The agent is based on
[? Collectee. ?] It's a package
of [? Collectee, ?] which is
a really popular open source
agent framework.
Today, we don't support custom
plug-ins to [? Collectee ?].
But as I said, support
for custom data
coming into the system is
really important for us.
So we know that
it's an important.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And the second question
is, what is the mechanism
to send my own logs to
the log infrastructure
that you provide?
TOBY SMITH: We have
a Fluentd agent
that we're using
on GCE instances,
that you'll be able to
configure to point to your logs.
AUDIENCE: All right.
And is there an endpoint that
I should send that up to?
I should install the Fluentd
agent on the instance
and send the logs to
wherever endpoint--
TOBY SMITH: You can just specify
where the logs are stored.
And we can configure the Fluentd
agent to find them there.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Cool.
Thanks.
DAN BELCHER: Great.
Thanks for your questions.
AUDIENCE: Two questions.
Does this add extra cost?
If I have a lot of logs flowing
in, am I paying for an instance
to maintain those or
is that sort of free
as part of the
rest of the system?
DAN BELCHER: So the
capabilities that we
showed you here today
are available to Trusted
Testers at no charge.
We don't have pricing
finalized for the service.
But it's our intent
for native things,
at a minimum, the
platform services,
to not charge for the
core monitoring for those.
OK.
And then the logging,
is there any--
TOBY SMITH: No,
there's no charge
for monitoring right now.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
And does this
provide or will this
provide more information
about the containers
in the external sort of the
equivalent of a physical PC,
or is this mostly just about the
operating system in the inside.
DAN BELCHER: Oh.
So could you restate
the question?
AUDIENCE: So this
seemed to monitor things
like my Linux and
my application.
Are there statistics
also for the outside,
the virtual PC, the
container, or what
I'm running on in the cloud?
DAN BELCHER: Oh the VM?
Well, out of the box, so
before you deploy the agent,
there are some metrics that
are available basically
with the hypervisor
looking at activity
between the
hypervisor and the VM.
So that would be
kind of core CP usage
and network and storage
I/O. But beyond that, no.
I don't think so.
Not really.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Cool.
But those come from the
hypervisor then the core PU?
DAN BELCHER: Yeah.
That's right.
Yeah.
Great question.
Any other questions or comments?
All right.
Well, thank you again, everyone.
Thank you so much.
Oh it looks like--
Yeah, you could come up and
ask questions after as well.
But it seems like we
have one more here.
AUDIENCE: So maybe a
heretical question,
but you started being an
amazing monitoring tool on AWS,
now you were acquired by Google.
Will you be able to do this for
both my AWS and my Google Cloud
usage?
DAN BELCHER: Well, we can't
really comment on future plans.
We're going to let
our customers help
to inform that decision
in the long run.
So certainly, there
are existing customers
using the Stackdriver product.
We plan to continue to
support them in perpetuity.
The support for AWS
and Google together
and other cloud
platforms and Google
together is something that
we're looking for our customers
to help us decide.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAN BELCHER: All right.
Thank you, everyone,
for your time.
TOBY SMITH: Thanks again.
[APPLAUSE]